how's everyone doing I know it's the
last tutorial hopefully you'll enjoy
this one so what is web scraping web
scraping is extracting information from
a website usually HTML and you parse it
in the readable format this is called
getting the soup so data sometimes it's
not always readily available to you
right ideally it's in a warehouse or
someone can send you a CSV but sometimes
that data doesn't exist and it exists on
the web page so you'll use beautifulsoup
to parse the web to get information so
the Python library will be looking at
its beautiful soup there are other
libraries called scrape B but I think
beautiful soup is really good especially
for beginners getting into web scraping
is not such a steep learning curve and
we'll use it to parse and Alex ML XML so
some best practices when you start web
scraping a page you want to check the
robots.txt file which exists on every
website to make sure you can web scrape
the actual website and we're going to
look for user agent field which is us so
let's take a look at Twitter's txt file
so when I go into Twitter's com
slash robots.txt we see this file so
these are the rules of web scraping so
you look for user agent which is here
so this is saying everybody this is
what's allowed and this is what is
disallowed so when you are web scraping
sometimes you will get an error or you
just can't parse that page and most
likely it's under the disallow areas of
the robots.txt file I tried doing that
on meetup the other day I try to web
scrape my RSVPs for meetup and I saw
that the RSVP web page was under
disallow so I wasn't able to do that
scraping too many pages at once quickly
can get your IP blocked so it's good to
have like a stop timer it's like a pause
really because then the website will
know you're a bot user browser developer
tool to determine the classes of objects
so when if you've ever seen this before
we're going to be web scraping Monty
Python and the Holy Grail and if you
guys don't know Python is inspired by
Monty Python and it's one of my favorite
movies so when you right-click there's
this developer tool call inspect and it
basically shows you the element that
you're looking at and what class it is
in the HTML right because how would you
know off the bat like what is the class
of this thing right here so when you're
web scraping and you want to find you
want to extract let's say this
information you will use the inspect
tool and you will see okay this is a
span class okay and what we'll get to
that so again you use a developer tool
and a parser so beautiful soup you need
other packages too to use beautiful soup
correctly you need requests and a parser
so scrapey which is the other package I
mentioned you don't really need those
those come pre-built in
so just so you know with beautiful soup
you also need these dependencies so if
you have anaconda okay you raise your
hand if you work with anaconda okay
looks like everybody in group you will
be installing some packages via your
terminal so in the windows I think it's
on your left hand side type in CMD and
you should pop up a terminal so in your
terminal you're going to write Conda
install and we're going to install these
packages so L XML you're gonna see an
error for me because I don't have an
account oh sorry I use Python pip so pip
is a Python manager of packages so I
would write pip install Alex ml so run
these commands and you will run cond
install LX ml which is your parser your
requests package and finally you will
also install beautiful soup for for to
see if you already have these packages
just go under Conda list and it'll show
you the list of packages you already
have in your terminal so for me I just
do pip list and it shows me all of the
packages I have and the version so again
you will do Conda list so I already have
beautiful soup l XML and requests so
let's take two minutes to install these
dependencies so if you need help
have your neighbor help you if they
already have it done or you can wave me
down so let's take like two minutes
okay everyone should have and saw the
packages by now so when I go to this
link you will arrive here so if you're
not familiar with github it's a repo
where a lot of websites and
organizations use to push out code if
you're wanting to get into the tech
space I highly highly recommend you have
a github if you don't have one right now
it's okay all you have to do is copy
paste so I would copy this open your
favorite text editor I like to use
sublime but idle is okay
Jupiter notebook is okay Adam so
whatever text editor you were using
before so I'm going to save this in
sublime and I'm going to save this as I
am
DV dot py it's really important to have
the dot py right cuz that's how you're
telling your computer this is a Python
file if not it's just gonna treat it as
text so you see here the colors are now
coded because it understands it's Python
so everyone has a the file downloaded
anyone raise your hand if you need a few
more minutes to download the file okay
so since we're dealing with packages
right with Python you have to import
them into your files so Python knows to
use them so you probably have already
done this in your tutorials like import
pandas as PD and so on so forth so we're
going to import requests and we're going
to import beautiful soup so it's from
bs4 import beautiful soup and it's
already there for you request dot get is
understanding this
as of the page so a 404 is a status of a
page right it's unable to be utilized so
if I were to print are we are running
through a URL here in the strings we are
like I said before we're web scraping
the Monty Python web page so I just
copied this and put it through in
strings into the get method under the
request packages so if I hope those are
the answers there we go
if I print our I I get response 200 so
that means okay this page is good to go
to be straight so one thing we have to
do is we have to get the text so I
create another variable called are on
parsed equals our text so let's print
what are on parse looks like so very
familiar right it looks like the source
of a page right with all the div
elements and the classes but
beautifulsoup doesn't understand what
this is we have to prettify it basically
in beautiful soup so beautiful soup can
extract the information so if I were to
perform methods I'm just on the on parse
just on the text beautiful soup doesn't
understand like the hierarchy right and
there's hierarchies in Python like lists
and dictionaries right so right right
now this is just a big blob of string so
that's why we parse it so I save it into
a variable called B so B equals
beautiful soup the function I pass
through the unpark sex and I use L XML
to parse it right so now if we print
be and I'm on it's a new computer on
Python 2 right here but if you were on
three you would do print B with
quotations so it looks similar right to
the HTML except it's now been parsed
through Alex ml I am just going to
change the display settings bear with me
so one of the advantages of parsing it
through L XML is it's faster so I'm
going to show you we're going to compare
if we parse it through Aleks ml through
HTML so we're going to use a package
called time and it's already part of
your default package systems so when you
want to use another package you have to
type it in you have to import it so
import time so we're saying start equals
time and equals time dot time because
python reads line by line right it's not
a synchronous so to know how long this
took we have to subtract so when we run
this oh thank you see python is very
finicky with syntax so this took um less
than a second and so will the HTML
parser but when you're you know parsing
through thousands and thousands of pages
like every bit counts and it adds up so
now let's use the HTML parser
so point O 9 versus point 13 again if
I'm just doing one page I might not
really care but this is you you
definitely want to consider
optimizations when you're dealing with
thousands and thousands of pages so I'm
gonna put it back to Alex and Mel so now
we have beautiful sue parsed this page
now we can actually extract information
from it so the first thing we're gonna
do is we're going to extract the title
and save it into a variable there's in
Python there's many ways that you can do
things like this I recommend reading the
beautifulsoup documentation to see like
what's like the best way so I will bring
that up so this is what the
documentation looks like as you scroll
through there's different methods
specific to beautifulsoup so we're
extracting a title most of the time on a
web pages that's like an h1 right but
beautifulsoup has its own method and
it's smart enough to know like what's
the exact title of that it's probably
looking for that h1 so there's two ways
to go about this I could find my mouse
so I'm saving it under title equals B
dot title dot text and when I print
title
[Music]
so now we have the title Monty Python
and the Holy Grail so like I said
there's other ways to find to do things
like this so be comfortable with like
the structure of an HTML you don't need
to know HTML very well but as long as I
can understand like the elements and
like I said the title can sometimes live
in the h1 so beautiful soup has a method
called dot finds so it finds the element
that you pass through so I know that
titles are usually in the h1 so if I say
print B dot find h1 dot txt it prints
out the same thing right we have to say
dot txt because that's another method if
I just removed it it would just give me
the object right and we want like the
string of it so dot txt is a very handy
method methods usually start with a dot
okay if there was more than one title we
would have to use the method find all
there's really just one title but if I
wanted to find all all elements like
span elements so if I do span it prints
out all of the elements okay so this is
helpful too well there's a lot of spans
but just know that on HTML pages there's
more than one element right there's not
always just unique elements so you want
to make sure that when you're trying to
find one make sure that are there other
elements also called this so there's a
lot of eight tags href right a lot of
divs so you want to make sure you're
finding the exact one and you can either
use this to find the exact name of it
and look through it or you can just
inspect the element right that's why I
highly recommend using the developer so
you're not like looking through all
these span elements you just highlight
over what you want hit inspect and it'll
tell you the name of it so we'll do that
to find the description so let's go back
so I'm just gonna mirror my thing this
is hard so the next thing we were going
to do is extract the description of it
so here's the description I use inspect
and I see
it lives under a div and the class is
called summary text right so you really
have to think about utilizing this
hierarchy so we're going to say
description equals B
don't find it's called a div right we
want to find the div but then we want to
know the exact it which is summary text
which we look through the inspect
element and then I want to take the text
and then I put strip to just take out
all like the whitespace
so when I print description oh I think
I'm still printing I'm still printing
the span so now I have the description
of the page King Arthur and his knights
of the round table embark on the surreal
low-budget search for the Holy Grail
encountering many very silly obstacles
so another thing I want to do is find
the rating and save it into a variable
this I found a little difficult because
there were many ways to go about this
and I'll show you why one way is better
than the other so looking through here
my first instinct was oh let me take the
rating from here right so when I mouse
over this I'm like okay it's a div and
it's under the class subtext
[Music]
so again I'm saying dot find the div
called subtext and print this
so subtext actually has a lot of other
stuff
it has PG the length of time a lot of
white space so it's kind of messy so my
first thought would be like let me just
get the let me just slice this data
right it's the first two characters but
this doesn't work all the time and why
would that be exactly pg-13 are right so
if I were to create a for loop and I
wanted to extract all the ratings of
different movies this mythology wouldn't
work so I went back and poked around I
poked around the page source which would
be in B so if I print let me print it at
the bottom and to me I like to just take
all of this and do a new file and just
like find PG there it is in the in the
span class but I did find this which is
not obvious on the page so hidden here
is some JSON JSON is a data format that
is very light and readable that we
usually exists in the web so JSON also
works like a dictionary if you're
familiar with Python dictionaries
there's like hierarchy and I saw here
that content rating was the key to the
value PG so I know that this was a clean
way of
the rating right I wouldn't have to be
taking that white space or if another
movie had pg-13 I knew that this would
be a clean way to get this so I had to
import a package called JSON and JSON is
available also as a default like time so
you want to import JSON so if I were to
use this again it's similar right things
will be seen before
I still use be dot find I'm finding the
script because it's titled that way so
here is the class it's a script the type
is application slash id+ JSON so it just
it's the same thing like classical
summary texts just the name of the class
so that's what I pass through the type
is application ID plus JSON I want to
get the text out of it and I strip it so
let's print this so we're getting there
that's the beauty of web scraping you
have to you know really work with these
hierarchies and these trees so we were
able to get what looks like a dictionary
so again the way some comfortable
dictionaries I know that if I want to
access
the key value I have to reference the
key so it's always after like a : so
this is the key equals the value so I
know I have to call that exact key so I
will then add and the way you call keys
is through brackets so I will say I want
the contact content rating oh yeah I
can't strip it this is why I have my
answer so I look back on context oh geez
what is different about this Oh
so I know that I need the json dot loads
and wrap that around b dot find so
that's when and that's when it
understands these dictionary hierarchies
i have to wrap this b dot find within
that that's why it was i'm giving me an
error so once I wrap json dot loads
within that I should get just the rating
isolated and here it is reading playing
twice okay so the next thing we're gonna
do so there's a lot of information
within this JSON file that it will make
my life much easier than having to go
through every single unique element
right these elements exist otherwise but
if it's all nice and like this
dictionary format I can just extract
more information
so other stuff that I might be
interested to extract are the actors
within the movie so this is a nested
dictionary right so actor is the key
value and holds all of these information
but within within this there are more
keys so name is a key and the value is
Graham Chapman right so you have to
drill down into this so let's do a fun
exercise with actors and we'll use for
loops I love for loops are very very
powerful so the same way we're going to
extract the actor so I just want to show
you why I need a for loop for this so
we're extracting the actors just making
no I think your file might have this
note already so the same way
I'm coffee and pasting but if you're a
beginner like please type it out it
helps like reinforce don't do what I'm
doing like copy and paste I'm just being
lazy and saving time but it really helps
you know type this out really reinforces
the learning so actors equals JSON
downloads basically the same thing and
what I want what I think I want is the
actor dictionary so if I print actors I
get all of that information right but
what I really want is the name of the
actors so that's why I would use a
for-loop to extract all of these because
there's more than one actor in a movie
so I'll just type this out together so
with for loops
start to the four so for actor in actors
my text editor sublime already indents
right so in the for loop it's indented
for you Python is very finicky with
syntax so with like creating functions
and for loops you always want to make
sure you don't forget like the indent so
before that I'm gonna create a empty
dick empty list write a list can hold
more than one thing and you initialize
it by just square brackets these are
empty because it can hold more than one
thing and I know there's more than one
actor that I want to extract so for
actor in actors I'm going to append into
my list of actors and what am i
appending I'm appending the actor so let
me let me actually just print actor in
case if anyone's not familiar with a for
loop I'm just gonna comment out these
other print statements okay so a for
loop goes through it iterates over and
over so the first line it looks at the
first key value and the second and the
third and the fourth so I know that in
the for loop it's looking at this first
line and then from this first line all I
want is a name so then I say actors list
on append actor I want the key value of
this u which is unicode and then I have
to print outside right to get outside of
my for loop and let's print the actors
list so now I have all of the actors
names that I want right right now it's
in Unicode so I'm actually gonna use I'm
gonna pass a string function and that
should turn Unicode into string so now
that's changed okay let's take like five
minutes and I want you to do the same
thing for the directors so actor is here
and if you scroll down you'll see
director there's actually two directors
who directed Monty Python and you're
going to create a for loop in the
director and appended to a list if you
want and extract the directors so I will
give you five minutes to do this and I
think it's now a good time for break two
in case if you also want to have a break
but let's spend some time and um do a
for loop for this
and I'll leave the actors up if in case
you want a reference but raise your hand
if you got it
nice job everyone alright so we're going
to take this and create a function so
that we can web scrape any other page
that we want so we're gonna extract use
what we learned do a movie of your
choosing and I want we're gonna create a
function that outputs all of this into a
dictionary so every function you define
by DF right I'm gonna call my function
movie dict and I am going to pass an
argument so when you're defining a
function you can or cannot pass anarchic
arguments you're choosing I'm gonna pass
argument called B because b is actually
no I'm not going to use that I will for
I'm getting ahead of myself
so first we're gonna create a function
for our for loop called actors so
basically take what you just did and
create a function for actors so I'm
going to define it and just like just
like the for loop right and we define a
function when you press enter after the
first line it indents it for you so
we're going to do the same thing actors
list equals for actor in actors
actors this startup and string actor I
want the name okay another thing that
you need to add to a function is return
right because if I wouldn't if I left
that out it basically wouldn't give me
anything I had to tell the function give
me something so I'm saying give me the
actors list that I created okay so you
can use a function within the function
and this is where we're going to do
because I don't want to have to write
all of this my new function I could just
reference my function in another
function so I'm defining movie
dictionary oh yeah and I pass an ID
right so every every IMDB page has a
unique ID and this is the ID that's
appended in the URL so I'm going to I
don't want to shout out a movie okay I'm
just gonna choose a drift then I think
was a true story right kind of crazy so
a drifts ID is up here right so I'm
passing through in the argument and ID
I'm just gonna again don't do this I'm
just being lazy so the first thing that
we do is get the request of that page
right so I use request I get just like
how
did all the way up here request I get
and I'm saying get the status of this
page so I like to use a function called
sorry a method called format so format
if you've never seen it before basically
takes what you the argument you put
through so I'm saying take ID which ID
comes from here so think of it as like a
funnel so the idea I pass through here
will then get appended into here so
format dumps things into where the curly
bracket think of it as like a
placeholder right so actually I can if
we just do this outside and then I say
return R and then I say I call my
function write my function is movie dict
and I pass through my new ID of the
movie so we're gonna pass a drifts ID
again there has to be in strings right
because python something know I need to
know like what data type it is so it's a
string all right let me print so there's
our response 200 right and that belongs
to what we output it here so I know okay
this website is scrape about any
questions with format it's a very handy
method so I know it works so I know I
can pass whatever ID I want and it gets
appended into this URL so let me just
delete that you know it works so then
I have to do all the steps right so
first get the requests I know
the response was fine I need to parse it
and I use el XML because it's faster and
it's just better and then I'm going to
initialize MT dictionary right so movie
underscore stick is my dictionary so the
key value that I want to pass the key
value that I want to declare is the ID
of the movie so I say move edict bracket
ID equals empty dictionary so this is
really the top of the funnel of my
dictionary so director is a key right
and keys are declared by brackets in the
dictionary so I'm saying the ID is gonna
be the main key and then I'm gonna have
a hierarchy of more keys just like how
director write director is the top of
the dictionary but then it has other
keys like type a URL and name so we're
going to do the same thing we're gonna
have a key called title and in that is
gonna be the text write the title of the
movie that's the value and then we're
going to declare another key which is
the description and we know that we just
use find div summary text dot extra
strip that gives us a description in a
clean format we already did the rating
right so this is all all web pages right
are like parent-child and they should
all have the same elements right that's
practicing like web development you're
not gonna have a new movie with
different elements and it's just very
hard to like maintain
so usually webpages are like templates
right just the content is different but
like the blueprint is the same so you
can create a function and they will work
on another page and this is really
helpful when you are web scraping many
different pages right you can get a lot
of the same information from many
different pages and you don't have to
recreate the wheel right because these
should be all of the same elements that
exists on another page so we're also
gonna get the actors right so and again
at the bottom I'm going to return the
dictionary so I'm gonna get all
information from adrift so I say I call
my function oh I'm sorry I jumped ahead
so actors is referencing my other
function actors that lives outside right
so you can reference a function within
the function and I pass through the
argument B because what what was B again
Python reads line by line where was be
up here B belong to monty python right
but now I'm saying B equals the text in
here and what is B now B is whatever
whatever webpage I want to scrape right
since this whatever I pass through here
gets dumped in here and then it finds
that URL and it parses that web page so
I'm saying when I say I want a drift I
have to pass
the ID of the page right and now this
will go here requests will get will
parse that web page instead of Monty
Python and when we print it no life
coding takes one argument takes no
arguments one given
one second don't have one called pandas
okay it works on my answers I'll check
on why it doesn't and a little bit on my
life coding but basically now my ID
belongs to a drift right I pass it
through the ID and now it's graped the
new information from my drift
we got pg-13 a description it matches
right on the description it takes the
actors right there's more than one actor
and the title so this is now a very
powerful function you can now scrape any
webpage that you want so I will blow
this up here and if you want take like
five more minutes or six minutes and you
can copy this and pass through any movie
that you want and see if it works so go
to IMDB pick the movie of your choice
and path through the ID again in string
quotations and see if you get all of
this information question
change its I'm sorry
oh that's where because it looks like
the same here right because I have ID
oh the B I never gave it the argument I
know I did right here oh oh I see I see
I see that's right
thank you see we're all learning
together okay I'll take a look at this
um but in the meantime use the one that
works and just write it over and pick
your own movie and see if it works
can anyone see okay do you want me to
make it bigger is that good
shrink the
one font smaller okay I think if you
need to look at it I'm gonna move
forward with looking at some blog posts
um but if you need to see the answers in
my github under web scraping the answer
file is there for you so if you want to
like reference back to it until my
github and you just find that the
powerpoints can send out right so or no
well if you want to write down this
bitly link or oh I just said my github
is money pit three right so you'll find
it there look looking at on this blog
post so again I I recommended um
beautifulsoup
this person wrote a really good
explanation of comparing the two I think
once you're pretty comfortable with
beautifulsoup you can upgrade to scrape
B it's basically creates like a spider
right and it'll be easier to crawl
through these web pages you don't have
to necessarily create like the for loops
like you would in beautiful soup and the
pauses but like this author says their
learning curve of scrapy is much steeper
and there's really good documentation on
beautifulsoup
I highly recommend web scraping as a
skill set I'm well I built my own
website on Django but I'm not like a
true developer I got my job but I work
with data and like I said earlier not
every data set is readily available for
you sometimes it lives on the web so I
think learning web scraping is a really
handy tool especially if it allows you
right remember to check the robots.txt
file if you can scrape down information
and it just gives you more data that you
didn't already have this person I saw
this after I did this exercise IMDB is a
very popular exercise to web scrape and
this person similar to what we did has
created dictionary they put it into a
panda's data frame so I recommend
looking at this this is part of data
quest a very good resource for learning
and they did web scraping with Python
and what they did was look through the
Advanced Search page and let me just
scroll down so same things here right
like they use the inspect developer tool
to look at like what are the elements
named because if you're not the web
developer creating these pages like you
don't you don't necessarily know what
they named these classes so it's a good
tool to you to see what you need to
extract from so they did basically what
we did here right so they created some
empty lists they looped through a
container which was basically up on the
web page it's a list of many different
movies and they loop through each movie
and got the name and the year and the
rating and we created a dictionary but
you can definitely create a data frame
and that's what they did here so I
definitely recommend also turning things
into data frames so you can analyze
multiple things so these are multiple
movies and the question was how did they
loop through that they just changed the
dates of on the URL right so they
couldn't just like Inc incremented so
they said the years for I in range of
2000
2018 so remember pythons not inclusive
at the end so it'll loop through 2000
through 2017 and here's some information
about controlling the crawl rate right
so you can pause it and I think that is
it for me I know we ended kind of early
so I can say around for questions or you
guys could get straight to I think the
party at 5:30 I sometimes just scrape it
I don't I mean it depends how much
you're scraping right but yeah people
have used selenium but at the end a like
you're still web scraping it so
sometimes it'll say disallow but you're
still allowed to like you still do it
but it's under but some are more savvy
like meetup like I cut in like I just
they block that off any other questions
yes
yes yes but as you saw it could scrape
like some JavaScript objects like
JavaScript objects like JSON right we
just imported so beautiful soup can
still do a line it just needs more
packages to help versus like I think
scrapy is like much more built-in how do
you guys feel about this good guys know
how to web scrape that yes yep yes sorry
there's someone in the back I'll get you
could you post the links to those blog
posts somewhere yes if a shameless plug
now like if you follow me on Twitter I
guess I could tweet it out okay so you
had a question
hi how are you so for Jason there is
something that I have come across is
called munch and basically you take a
JSON object and you run it through the
mancha 5 function and it produces what
it looks like an object with properties
that resembles your full object graph
it's I guess it's like beautiful soup
but for Jason mm-hmm yeah and we
imported JSON the actual the function
was json dot loads so maybe it's it I'm
not really familiar with munch but I
look into it but with json dot loads the
function from that package we were able
to extract information like a dictionary
the other questions thank you so much
for coming I had a lot of fun and then
now you can go forth and web scrape just
check the robots.txt file you don't want
the FBI come I'm just kidding that's not
gonna happen thank you
[Music]